and you'll never find me
oh my god oh my god oh my god hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back
to five nights at freddy's been a while
since i said that oh would you look at
that
ain't that delightful one second hold on
hold your goddamn horses ray tracing
really i mean
maybe is it going to make my computer
run like a piece of pizza subtitles on
small on large all right new game
warning this game contains jump scares
caution is advised for people okay
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
mornings are for nerds entertainment
would like you to put your hands
together for the one the only freddy
fazbear
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
now there it is
i was wondering when this is gonna
happen
[Applause]
alert delicious frontal lobes detect oh
never mind
it's uh passing out time i wonder if
this is all just a precursor to open up
one of these as an actual restaurant
because you know in any other context
this would be really weird if you told
me like six years ago that this would be
what
fazbear would be like i would have been
kind of confused not saying i'm not
confused right now and also it looks
like my computer's running like poop
maybe that ray tracing was a little too
much oh god help me i'm trapped in the
in the two frame per second universe ray
tracing please
god my computer is still stuck from six
years ago help hang on wait wait wait
wait
hold on technical difficulties not only
froze bearers getting glitchy i'm
getting glitchy there we go that's not
running like turds
that's running better there we go that's
the good stuff
showtime already
i am experiencing a malfunction
the recharge cycle is not complete will
you shut up oh who said that i did
and down here down where i still do not
see you okay listen you were sleeping so
i opened the stomach hatch and climbed
inside my stomach hatch
that place is reserved for oversized
birthday cakes and pinatas it is not a
safe play area
oh
exit freddy well
do i want to
oh hi there you are hey
ah no please no thank you scanning
complete
how art
your guest profile is unknown to me
uh-huh who are you
uh markiplier oh there i am
i'm gregory ignore the voice that's
coming out of my mouth
i will notify the main office
connection error
i cannot connect to the main network
it's her she cut you off
she's not going to let you call for help
until she finds me
who is looking for you
your mother
i hear footsteps
what window
am i dumb or is there no window here
sarah when oh
that is the security guard she can help
no no i don't trust her why not i don't
know who she is but she's trying to get
me isn't there some other way for you to
communicate with me besides talking so
loud i'm gonna hold on technical
difficulties hold on everyone hush look
look hey we're going on small
ah take this
it is a novelty freddy fast watch uh
okay thank you
that was in there i was in there
how was i in there
stop looking at me what if i don't want
to take your watch i feel like i would
have known that was in there alright
whatever
i'll take it
i don't like that
oh good yeah
uh-huh
what was that i'm sending you an encoded
message what year are we in hello
gregory it is me freddy i will escort
you to the main entrance however i am
unable to leave this room
you should have no problem there is a
button on the wall that will open the
door to the back room i will make it
accessible to you now
this is a novelty watch this is dope as
hell
this is cool
how expensive is this normally press the
find
freddy button
huh i'm not dumb oh
find the freddy button not the find
freddy button there is an open air vent
inside the maintenance room you will
have to climb through the ventilation
system and release me from the outside
why
why is that a good idea
it's pretty dark in there there is
nothing to be scared of
you can do it
okay let's be honest we're playing a
five nights at freddy's game there's
plenty to be afraid of but i'm gonna go
ahead
wasted enough time on the menus hi okay
that was no need to shut the door
why would you do that
hi
who are you
aren't you cute and or terrifying and or
both
so
press an oldie to save your swan take
some time so keep an eye out yeah you
you right yeah you right
hi bud
new slot
okay
hi big charging tube
all right oh
jump thank you tutorial i know how to
jump i've played games before once or
twice
i did it
i did it your performance was perfect
tonight
thank you
your hair is beautiful
your tail is beautiful
everyone was watching you
everyone loves you
everyone wants to be you
you are the best
thank you
i am the best
i
am the best uh well okay i hate to burst
your bubble there but i'm actually the
best so you can shut up fans are
watching you right now
i know
all right okay all right
well
roxy was it roxanne i believe
lovely meeting you
i endure your personality
and i think that you're going to go far
and everything you're saying is true
probably and someone's taking a dome
someone's taking a very aggressive and
violent
someone's taking a murderously intense
dump well so far so
normal hello
the i think the game is wanting me to
think this is the gator but i'm gonna
choose to believe this is glam rock
chica just really tearing up the town
all right you have fun yeah fun chica
i'm gonna go hello
[Music]
how sentient are these things i mean
they've always been a little
pseudo-sentient
uh what with the
souls of dead children stuffed within
them and all all right i gotta go thanks
and i'll see you around whoa
where is this
oh
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
visiting and we hope you enjoyed the
show
freddy and the gang are pretty tired but
they'll be back again next week after a
few days of scheduled maintenance
please make your way to the front of the
building where you will be given novelty
glasses a voucher for one free soda
refill and where you will sign a legal
disclaimer releasing us of all liability
for anything that might have happened
during your visit
have an awesome night and we'll see you
again soon
okay all right sounds good thank you
about that
hi
hey how you doing good to see you
wow i really uh really know
when uh there's something to watch out
for um
well this is all lovely and very uh
acknowledging of the darker parts of the
universe
uh
but
what is that about peekaboo well this is
lovely but i gotta get going
i think
maybe hi tikka
[Music]
okay all right that's great excuse me
okay hey
hey how you doing monty
monty
all right i'm on to you uh
you have fun
hello can you see me in your mirror i
bet if i was standing directly behind
you you wouldn't notice anything about
yourself and i respect that
i respect that greatly
okay bye now oh hey that's not creepy
hi you sending me an encoded message
release freddie from his room yeah okay
good idea
best idea actually now that i think
about it
now i'm really putting the stupid door
won't
you open going to need a photo pass to
open the door
apologies i assumed you had one already
that's okay well you should be able to
find one at a convenience counter okay
what is that blocked on target
blocked on target no it's the stupid
things again
i thought you were a convenience counter
nah
that would have been too easy can i go
through here hi i'll crawl don't slam on
me
thank you
well this is lovely
one free photo pass
sign me up
hey
all right good good job now please come
let me out okay
and what's gonna happen when i do that
do you know what happened when i do that
is you gonna wait to go superstar
i knew you could do it thank you know
how to get you out of here climb back
into my chest cavity just still time but
we must hurry if i am spotted i will
certainly be taken back to my room i
will escort you to the main exit through
the utility tunnels it is the safest
path okay but you better be careful
moving around i don't want to be crushed
and twisted into a meat pretzel
how did i get in there in the first
place
bots cannot find gregory when he is
controlling freddy
great
all right room for one
thank you
i'm very compact
okay get
out
i will get out
gonna be real stealthy about this
oh god all right all right
okay
oh my god what the hell
excuse me
all right cool all right hey wow
hi
oh you're bothersome
i don't like you
and also why are you moving at a lower
frame rate than anything else i don't
like that
she's down here we have to go back do
not worry gregory even if we are spotted
you are safe with me
she would never suspect we are traveling
together
however we should still do our best to
avoid her if i am sent back to my room
we will never get to the lobby before
midnight
what
why am i here
and also why am i running away from the
security guard lady
and can i jump down there i can't jump
damn
it connects perfectly to the sewer why
can't i jump
oh
why can't i jump in
i feel you are broken don't worry about
it i'm fine no
i feel that something is wrong
i am taking you to the first aid station
there's no time i'm fine
oh
okay
hey thanks pal
really preach
biggest preach
i'll just slip right in oh god
freddie
you're supposed to be on lockdown
uh officer vanessa i i do not know how i
got here
well you totally blew it tonight you
know your system crashed and you ruined
the show now parts and services have you
on reduced power they said it's a safety
precaution
just one more thing to deal with i
apologize
okay
look we're like 15 minutes from closing
and some kid is sneaking around
backstage if you see anything notify me
immediately
i already alerted the others
now go back to your room
okay thanks vanessa
i told you she was after me i said
nothing i will keep you safe
let us go
okay thanks also why also what also who
also let me in
thank you
free
uh wash your paws moon drop all right
where are we going
why did i need to go to the first aid
station i didn't seem to get any first
aid
where are we we are now under the pizza
plex these utility tunnels connect all
the attractions we can go anywhere in
the building correct
fazerblast monty golf roxy raceway they
are all accessible to staff with high
enough clearance of course
guests are never allowed down here but
yours is a special situation
okay i'm not gonna question this oh
low power
that seems like a problem
all right i guess i'll just go
uh goodbye then
see you later
freddie's out of power he's unable to
help until the start of the next hour
i am terribly sorry
the recharge cycle had not yet completed
when i found you
you must continue without me
i will guide you on your fast watch in
case you get into any trouble i don't
know if i can do this alone
do what alone exactly
whoa
hey bud how you doing
hey good to see you
okay all right freddy all
present
what did i get
hello
hello i can't get to the missions tab
all right well never mind then
okay oh god i'll save this please
true hey how are you doing
all right cool
all right
oh hey
maybe i could distract her with
something
to knock over objects and distract bots
don't get spotted
or
hey how are you doing hey what's going
on oh my god
all right well that didn't go
well actually that went exactly how i
thought it was gonna go but it didn't go
according to how i wanted it to go which
is different than how i thought it was
gonna go
it's called hope okay let's try that
again hey
hi
[Music]
maybe i could distract her with
something maybe i could
i could take a nice
piss and that'd be distracting
um
i'm assuming you wanted me to throw
something but i don't exactly know what
i'm gonna oh
maybe this
at me oh don't look at me don't look at
me i'll look at you ow hi
i shoulda you know i didn't really that
didn't go how i wanted it to go
nor how i thought it was gonna go so i
was wrong on both fronts oh my god how
do i know to do this oh wow weird
so strange
i'm guessing that i can just go red
means i've been found i seem to remember
seeing red before i think that meant i
was found
can i just go
please don't come back in here also were
you eating garbage
that doesn't sound like fitness for food
oh thank you
i'm fine
you're fine we're fine hey
we're all fine
100 of phaseable accidents involve human
beings
well you're right
and i have nothing else to say about
that
sprinting
you can't run forever
yeah it's ominous
but also why do i need to run
do i need to run
i'm assuming i don't
or else there'd be like loud music
following me and some kind of stomping
mechanical sound
of a monster about to eat my bones
hi nope
okay
oh this is the other way around huh it's
almost like they put a loop here in case
something was chasing me and a monster
was stopping behind me wanting to chew
my bones
but that couldn't possibly be the truth
oh safe station something they would
they would put here right before
something comes stomping after me
wanting to cheat to my bones that's
definitely not the case here hello
sir
ah something stuffing right behind me
tell me you don't want to chew my bones
well you're not very fast if a little
kid can outrun you why you
you must so my god run faster now
okay hey how you doing no i'm not lost i
know exactly where i am and where i'm
going do you
oh my god oh my god oh my god
hey all right
man i'm just a whiz at stairs
[Music]
oh this looks familiar you found a
security office you should be quite safe
here oh yeah doors were designed to keep
our highly trained security staff safe
in the event of an emergency
as long as the doors stay closed which
they will
as long as there is ample power
freddie
the power's only at 15 and they're
pounding on the door
it seems like a lot of privilege to give
a child
your fast watch is now connected to the
security camera system
check the map those boxes on your
mini-map are nearby security cameras
when movement is detected by the
camera's motion sensors you should see
red alert icons
switch between the cameras to find a
safe path out of the office and to the
main lobby
uh-huh
yeah i see okay okay so
that cheek is
patrolling there
oh i see oh i see okay
all right well that's fine
okay so that means you're over there
that means my time to go would be
exactly now i should save my spot
this is gonna according to plan i'm just
gonna blitz it
that always works
who needs hiding places when you got
speed
when you got demonic speed on your side
oh chica
if only you weren't
so incredibly stupid that you didn't
know that something was woo
all right oh my god it's red oh it's red
what do you mean red
don't
collect what do you mean what am i
collecting why am i collecting something
those are collectibles
i got a cheeky pinata oh my run
smoothies
[Music]
now what am i supposed to do how
unfortunate gregory
you missed your chance
but there is still hope you should be
able to escape when the security doors
reopen at 6am
until then
keep moving
and try not to draw attention to
yourself
if there is another way out i will help
you find it
i promise
okay cool thanks preesh um but how and
why and also why didn't i just leave
earlier why didn't i follow the security
guard
unless there's some dark secret with
that security guard that we're all gonna
find only hi
oh that trash can is cute okay
well
this is an enlightening experience and i
can't wait for this to
hi
why do you
move at a slower frame rate than
everything else
yes what you got something to say say to
my face oh okay it's actually a bro hey
oh where did you come from
i don't know
i can't seem to there i'm running
all right good
can't go through there styles require a
complimentary pizza plex entry pass
that's probably there
located near the main entrance ah sure
well i'm at the main entrance and
there's a bigger problem currently and
you'll never find me
wow that's a surprise
huh
hey
all right so don't go accosting the
mop bot
and
be less stupider than i previously
should be one was near the main entrance
yeah where
the aware
where
get a complementary
and aha
i'm a genius those are cute
i like those
okay hello hi
why didn't i notice this before
maybe i'm dumb
don't agree with that hey entry pass
sorry forgot you were there for a moment
all right
so the trick is to not be
the dumb
unfortunately that complimentary entry
ticket does not allow you to enter the
pizzeria you can find an upgrade machine
in customer service
uh-huh
it's oh my god stop
i think this is a thing hey
who me no
never
what why
okay got that whatever that is what did
i get i didn't even oh my
oh
my god
why how do you know my name
a hidey
hole easy peasy
might as well get a picture of my
excellence while i'm here
idiot
camera where em is i
this
dumbass is downstairs
oh is you're upstairs now that was you
coming from the down to the up
this dumbass doesn't know where i am
what are you an idiot
bird brain
dumbass that's great that's great that's
great don't don't don't don't
you stupid
bird
you're so
dumb
can you please go back downstairs i
really don't want to have to do this who
wants candy well i do but that's not the
time for it
okay thank you okay upgrade at the
upgrade machine
whatever that means
all right she's downstairs
all right
what did that say about my
yeah whatever
you're not an upgrade machine you are a
sweet ride oh a distraction i was about
to press that superstar daycare pickup
glam rock gifts
these all sound great
oh hey okay don't jump scare me
don't
don't don't don't don't
don't don't how how much do you want to
bet that these are almost already on
sale all these plushies
if they're not
they are
definitely not milking this who is that
i don't know
okay where am i i don't know where i am
oh it's a way to go upbeat and downey
ah it's an uppy downy
zone hmm
free mystery prize love that
i found the free gift uh it's a crappy
mr hippo fridge
magnet lame
i am sorry gregory
i am
truly sorry
why are you why do you say that like i'm
about to die
i mean i am but why would you say it
like that
all right
okay well this is open now but i don't
know if that helps me
uh okay well this has been an
enlightening experience but i gotta
upgrade my ticket or else i'm gonna die
and i don't wanna die
oh god you're still here
love the jazz
i don't even think about don't even
think about doing anything you're
thinking about it stop thinking
immediately
okay cool
oh my god wait whoa
hey
idiot
dumbass
all right where's this goddamn thing
where's this daggum thing
hey bud don't don't you're thinking
about it you need to don't
you need to don't
and swoosh
nope
what do i have one
what did i get
i don't know what i got
easy money
it's a staff chica has been caught
eating from the kitchen garbage after
hours maintenance
okay oh
swoosh
idiot
well that's cute whoa
hey
okay
open that up so i can get back is this
an upgrade thing is that an upgrade
thing
oh
do i have money
it ain't my pass try that terrible
magnet you found
oh apparently i needed that i'm so smart
oh god i killed him scrambled the
machine i killed happy healthy he'll be
happy now it's some kind of daycare pass
that is great news i will meet you in
the daycare the entrance is on the
second floor balcony
uh-huh
okay
hey
hi dave customer complaint you should
fire dave he sucks
all right
good to know okay okay okay you're there
but that's fine
nope my friend
no no no no
no they can't no no no no no no
no
this day care looks a little ominous
oh
i'm gonna go ahead and say no
hi
okay
i don't like whoever this character is
seems like there's another character
complimentary to that one freddy are you
in here
okay
well i'm gonna save because clearly
something's about to happen
some i'm not gonna like but that's all
right
oh
hey
oh yep don't like that
i don't think babies would develop their
mental state well good good
i don't think that's good for babies
i'm gonna go ahead and say it
i am unable to reach you
check the daycare security desk for a
security patch
[Music]
there's an alarming amount of security
necessary in this place
yeah i'd be scarring okay where's the
security desk you're not gonna tell me
where so i gotta go find it
but whatever
slide into fun
well you know not gonna lie that does
look fun you just throw a couple kids in
there let them go at it yeah it sounds
pretty fun all right
oh yeah
i went up that's strange
i'm here now
well this is great
hate
hate it hate why is it in here with
new me you're sure i'm late are we
having a slumber party where are all
your friends
we can finger pay tell stories drink
fizzy bass into our heads explode and
then stay up all night there is only one
rule
keep the lights on
on
okay cool thanks buddy hey are you
having fun yet are are you
okay so there's not two characters it's
a high okay
well
okay all right well this is
uncomfortable hey distractions
okay thanks man
okay you uh do whatever it is you're
doing and i'm gonna go wherever i'm
gonna go
oh god
hi okay hey
didn't know you were coming aft this is
strange
a little weird
[Music]
okay
a little ocd but that's all right
oh
no why would you do that lights on light
sun
i want you i want you
it's past your bedtime
you must be punished
okay what purpose does this serve for
the education and care of children
i guess it's daycare not nightcare
but the lights are out in the daycare
you need to find the emergency backup
generators and turn them on they are in
the play structures
daycare night death all right oh
sure
uh-huh
can i close this thanks
okay well um
okay they're in the play structures you
got it pal
righty ho
good yeah this is here for babies to
find
[Applause]
good yeah that's that's fine
let them play around with the wires you
know
it's all good why does the net go up
that high
how high do these babies jump
oh
oh hey there you are
well that was a little did you go in
that play structure
i didn't know that was part of the
experience
okay just gonna uh i'm stuck
oh oh how do you do that
you didn't tell me you could fly
hey all right okay i'm gonna go in this
play structure uh can i still do a
distraction can you not know which way
yeah yeah yeah clean up clean up you
clean that up you clean that up
you clean that up
i don't know where this is going
i don't know where the wire is i know
it's somewhere in there
wire
wire wire okay wire
what
how does that make sense
where the hell am i what
no
no hi okay you can't get me in here
right i'm really hoping that that's a no
okay almost maybe
maybe a little bit
maybe i'm here we go
to a five
all right that's fine
do we gotta do
put me in the pair wiggler
it's all part of the job
[Music]
where i know there was another cable i
saw over here
damn i'm good
damn i am good oh there you are
okay are you currently sprinting at me
as if you're gonna kill me because it
doesn't seem to be working
or you just sitting there waiting
i think you're sitting there waiting
okay
i don't know if there's gonna be another
one around here
i think this cable just leads up
yeah
yeah no it's just that light
okay well
you still there oh there you are oh i
see
a little strange
there you go you did it good job
i could knock over that thing
then maybe i could wow oh my god
i was in the tube i was in the tube
i was in that tube do i have to do all
those again
i'm guessing yes this is five nights at
freddy's redoing work is all part of the
experience
i don't know if there's a way to go
across here without just going out in
the open aha there
is that sounds close
that's a problem that's the problem i'm
mounting you up and no no i'm going to
go up this tube
because
no no no no no
no they don't no they won't no they
shone they shall not be punished
no no no knock no
no knock
knock
no okay
i got the three i got the before
so if there's more around here
uh i don't know if they're gonna
go away i don't even know where you are
i don't like where you are i don't like
who you is
that children must be punished what is
that about
that's weird
oh
oh okay that
yeah that's fine
yeah that's so funny
all right i i could kind of see like red
light
um
wait i just saw red light down there
okay so that's another one so if i go
down
that would be four
maybe
yeah
oh god where was it i saw it it was down
here
oh shoot
good night
i see a red light in there
that's one okay that's the other one
that's not the one i'm looking for right
now because i know i saw one more
in here
what a maze
i think i'm just going in a circle
oh
are you right there
are you like right there oh my god
you're right there oh my god what do i
do about that
nothing i run i run that's what i do i
go away
i saw it i saw it
i seemed it
okay i think this is gonna give
good me
or this got me right outside oh
shoot
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for it i'm
going for it
hate that hate that hate that
no no please i don't want it okay
perfect thank you okay i know where the
last one is
oh my god run get up
get up and run there's one right here oh
my god how do i get in there oh my god
give me give me in let me in let me in
let me in let me in let me in let me in
where am i i can't see anything where am
i
who am i what am i doing
oh my you
i had them okay what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna find
the ones on the ground first because it
seems like the ones on the ground are
the dangerous ones and once i get
actually up i'll be able to do something
about it
no thank you no thank you
okay there was one on the ground here
that was like behind some
things
here maybe
oh wow that's
well that was right in front of me
where was the thing i saw it was like a
star thing in the window
there was like there was it was there
was oh
there's oh there's mult oh i see
well how do i
how the hell
oh that's the one i got there's a whole
nother structure
oh
oh i'm done my children must be found
must they
must they be
found must they really
[Music]
i know there's one yeah right here okay
and then there's one on the far side of
this upper level i know that
where though i do not know up here okay
this is number four up here right
this last one i'm pretty sure is over
yonder way
right about where he is now
i think
if i remember
oh god oh god oh god distraction yes
please
oh look at that huh weird
i think it's up here i think
it's pretty sure it was over here
maybe i'm wrong
oh god
no don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't
don't
i just sworn it was up here but i think
i just
i know yeah it's uh it's a pain in the
ass
i'ma run out of battery i'm gonna run
out of battery
i'm gonna go battery up
i'm gonna batter oh god give me
something to clean up clean up clean
up my new friends this area is off
limits you're gonna get us in trouble
i don't know don't you wanna pop a
challenge i have glitter glue you like
glitter glue
oh god oh god oh god
clean up run dammit goddamn shift toggle
is bad
okay am i dumb or was there not or was
there was something here to get me and
the the thing with the thing i
i swear in this maybe this one up the
top maybe it wasn't the far side one
might not have been i guess
oh god what the hell get it no get it
clean up clean up
horrible oh
terrible i'm so sorry
okay i'm gonna follow this wire because
i think this is what i'm talking about i
i think for some reason my brain
scrambled the information
no i got
no ground floor of this one wasn't there
one on the ground floor of this one no
yes maybe so i don't know
you you you you yeah no
how did i get you all ready
god what it what is this
there's nothing there's nothing it's
nothing sorry
oh god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god no
not when i've been four or five for so
long
you didn't clean this up
you dumb ass
clean it up oh
you think i broke him i think i broke
him
is it finally being like man this guy's
so dumb can't find the last one
i got the one up there
there isn't one down here
i think i broke him
i legitimately think i broke him okay
one there
that one
there is on the one at the top of that
one is on i know there's two on here
that means there's got to be one more
here that i'm not finding
right
that it has to
it must mean that
oh my god
oh
you
son of a it was on the bottom
floor
the whole damn time
it's like two inches from how
did i miss you
i'm fine
i'm good
god you don't know how long i was
looking for that and there's no excuse
there's no excuse there's no excuse
there's no excuse all my fault i take
full responsibility
i take full angry responsibility
mr sun man where'd you go
i got a word
pick with you
what am i doing
where am i going oh maybe i go out the
big doors
no no all right yes
hi you are banned from the daycare
alert security
alert
gregory jump in we need to get out of
here okay okay okay
hey chica hey how you doing this is me
freddie from go upstairs
and do not worry they cannot find you
while we are together hi
okay
all right
okay guys
uh excuse me
excuse me
what
what did you say to me
you bet i don't even have friends what a
cruel thing to say time we need to get
to a recharge station immediately every
hour the power is diverted to the
recharge stations when that happens the
lights go out and when that happens the
daycare attendant is free to run the
buildings
uh
wha
why
what
but why doe
but
can you punch him
i think you're stronger than him he's
like bones what did i get i don't know
where
all right whatever i'm outta here baby
see you around nerds
see around
our later chumps
didn't you just stay in a recharge
station
is this gonna affect my bones or
something like that
am i gonna be okay after this
am i okay now
during this
what was that that is a fountain a
fountain is a decorative reservoir used
for discharging water
not the fountain
he didn't see the dancing rabbit lady
right in front of us no
i did not
there is no rabbit at the mega pizza
plex
not anymore
this is crazy
it's like the whole place is trying to
get me i am not
why i
do not know
i want to help you
maybe they want to help you too
i doubt it
for some reason
you're different
wow
we are just that good of friends
the front doors will open in five hours
good news
five hours
i'm not gonna last five minutes do not
panic if we get separated again you can
always call me on your fast watch
as long as i have power
and i am able to reach
you aha okay so i got my own personal
freddie on call well thank you that's
very kind of you you're a little scuzzed
up what happened to you you swim through
the sewers
alright whatever i don't have any
questions about that right now i've
gotta save because i'm all out of time
for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you're enjoying security breach so
far it's definitely a different
departure from a lot of like the
previous five nights at freddy's i mean
big open roam and all that um
it's got some quirks to it definitely
but i love the style you know i can't
fault it for that it's definitely got
the style there so thank you everybody
so much for watching i'll look forward
to more of this coming at you very soon
i'm probably just going to do it hour by
hour or maybe a little more depending on
how i feel uh also
you want this you want this sweet new
cardigan this cloak cardigan this
cardigan cloak this cloak again go to
cloakbrand.com to check out my new
butter collection it's uh probably the
most comfortable stuff i've ever made
i've been wearing this literally
non-stop if you see my videos recently
it's literally been nothing but this
link's in the description also bob wade
and i founded a new podcast it's called
distractible if you want to check out a
funny podcast where we tell funny
stories and we try to make each other uh
smarter then check out distractable
through the link in the description or
just go to your favorite podcast place
and check out distractable thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]